[Music]
what is it like to be in what people say
will be be biggest movie in the history
of the world in the history of the
planet right which is pretty crazy
I mean movies haven't been around for
much but yeah the biggest movie in
history that probably will happen what's
he feeling feels pretty pretty
remarkable what do you I was a part of
the biggest movie of all right right and
that was a very surreal experience um
that made you cocky afterwards cuz like
every time like another movie comes
around and sort of like tries to top but
you're like you know yeah but I feel
very blessed to know that I've done it I
have a second opportunity to to be a
part of something so big and impactful
you know on a global level and that
makes you feel very small which is a
very humbling experience it makes you
feel I love that you did remind us
there's like the blue you but it was
still you and you're like hey please
I've been here I've been to the
motherland before um what was it like on
set with all those trailers like how
many trailers were it's a massive
massive production I mean you do is the
base campus was huge I think it was a
185 shoot days yeah I wouldn't whatever
just like sweating your eyes and you see
just what a logistical nightmare that is
for someone but for us it was really fun
because every time you turn the corner
as a new movie star that you've always
wanted to work with that's there you
they give you a hug but who had the
sweetest trailer Downey Downey City
yeah of course it wasn't even a true is
like a village yeah his own base camp
yeah
it's like his whole yeah he is Tony
Stark in real life yes oh so say he's
there now is he he's that guy yeah what
can you tell us about the movie cuz
nobody in the free world is seen of
totally I can tell you that it's you
know it's really an unprecedented feat
this is there have been 18 films leading
up to this moment over the course of 10
years each I was like spoilers Chris I
don't want you to you see you're giving
me the political I want spoilers now I
want you to drop something drop it right
now just boom we haven't seen it what no
no first time
I don't even know if I'm in it I know
did you bake it it's gonna be I'll tell
you what it's gonna be good and you're
gonna see stuff you're gonna see all I
can do is speak to the guardians the
galaxy you'll see us involved in a very
real way you'll see some real meaningful
stuff that's not just a drop in I mean
we're a big part of the movie and I
think people are really gonna be excited
with what we have in store for them
once they're a like a trailer or a
playground for all the kids when you did
you have with any of the kids on the set
or was it like oh yeah
I mean I think I only brought one of the
twins one day but it was it wasn't um
the kind of sat and the kind of you know
settings that was safe for years it was
a lot of you know tractors and a lot of
like cranes and things like that and we
were shooting in in lots that they had
they would build this this intricate set
and around it were just tools so I was a
nervous wreck I did not want to bring
the twins there really but one of them
did come and he was at that time he was
the quiet one cuz they they changed the
twins and he sat in a chair and and the
Russos came and they said hello and he
was very much in awe of like all the
costumes and makeup that everybody had
your done the freak you kids out when
they see that like especially at that
age where they're like I think my boys
are ready I mean their mom is green
right they had to deal with that at a
very early age and it was it was a very
sunny day you know they were kind of
paralyzed they were just like yeah I
remember I remember you with with uh
with them when you you would FaceTime
them and you'd be in all your green and
they get they got used to it did you
come down I came over if he came to this
Center or not um but it's a concept now
he's not five and a half it's like I'm
being on set for him his kind of old hat
you know he's like yeah been there done
that he just goes right to the monitor
puts on the context sits down he's like
watching the monitors he's like
he's growing up in the circus for sure
he's what you like but they like to go
to the craft table service yeah he's
like a movie veteran how he feels like
it yeah he's been in a lot of sense
all right so real quick I'm gonna ask
you a series of questions you tell me
which Chris okay
you just tell me which Chris okay if
these were lollipops would be awesome
yeah okay which Chris Britton ladies
[Laughter]
look into my eyes and this was jazz
hands okay wait Chris do you think
ladies swoon over the most no yeah
that's not there you go that's a nice
answer which Chris did most of their own
stunts
he's a tap dancer okay
okay which Chris is more like masculine
dancer which one is more likely to enter
wet t-shirt contest oh and here's
Hold'em this is the one which Chris
spray tans the most no bring that home
you know what's up okay
I know you guys have to go but Chris can
you do me a favor yeah um we got
explicit directions to never go into the
fridge in our suite oh cool you want
some champagne or something but if
there's something in there that you saw
that you wanted so you could have real
nice what do you really like to drink
did you also see the fridge fridge I
don't I don't want this one
let's hit the crystal
only not allowed to open that but I mean
a crystal I mean if you opened it we
might as well take it I mean come on oh
oh we're celebrating cheers guys Cheers
Jelena thank you thank you for your
welcome I mean it's the least I could do
Wow Wow
that's the West what crystal tastes like
Chris Russell Chris was different now we
always have best Chris
[Music]